My name is Amrou Al-Kadhi
or Glamrou.
And I have an identity that you might
categorise as intersectional.
I'm British-Iraqi,
gay, non-binary
and also identify as Muslim.
And reading about quantum physics
has really helped me understand
my queer identity.
Quantum physics is a beautiful,
strange and glorious sect of physics
that looks at the subatomic
particles that govern our world.
So, inside the neutrons,
electrons and the protons
you're looking at the quarks,
leptons, bosons and the Higgs.
Whereas classical
Newtonian physics is
obsessed with the universal formula
that govern our reality,
it's so fixed on resolute answers.
Quantum physics reveals
that there is no fixed reality
and it's full of beautiful
contradictions.
We can now observe that the same
sub-atomic particle
can be in many
places at the same time.
So if we fire an electron through a
wall with two holes, for instance,
we should be able to see that it goes
through one or the other.
But, on a quantum level
when you observe what's going on,
we see that the same particle
is actually going through
both holes at the same time.
Multiple versions of the same event
are happening all at the same time.
What's so remarkable about quantum
physics is the fact that
what's happening
on a subatomic level
contradicts what we're actually
seeing happening in reality.
It shows us that reality
is itself a construct,
and what's going on
internally on a subatomic level
belies what we're actually observing.
Quantum physics
to Newtonian physics is, to me,
what queer theory
is to heteronormativity,
i.e. looking for normative constructs
of society -
male, female,
of gender, of race
categorising everything
in a neat, rigid way.
I am very comforted by this
as a queer person
with no real fixed identity.
It gives me immense hope that there's
this model of the world.
This real
physical, philosophical model
which shows us that reality
is just a set of contradictions
with no real fixed foundation.
It is in this model of space-time
as a series of entanglements
that I'm able to piece together
all of the fragmented sects
of my identity -
being able to identify
as British and Iraqi,
as queer and Muslim,
as someone of many genders
and potentially no genders at all.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)